what do you think is the role of family
in wrestling
can a man do it alone and if not
where's family most important you know
you can do it alone
but why would you want to yeah i think
the chances of doing it alone are
much less than the chances of doing it
together yeah
i know they say don't bring your
profession home sometimes they say that
this might never i never got away from
my profession yeah
and you know sometimes i it's like
my house right here so when i'm
moving home and i'm not going to have an
office
because i'm not going to coach anymore
or i'm not going to be an assistant
athletic director for a while
that you got to do something that
gives you a little bit of a break not
you necessarily maybe the person you're
living with
and so i don't know if you looked
outside there i got a cabin right out in
my backyard you probably can't see it
right there but
what's in the cabin that's my house away
from my house it's only
30 feet from my house and it's my office
and it's my workout room it's my i got a
sauna there it's
it's a bed upstairs if i need it if i
ever uh
get too close and she says hey why don't
you go sleep in the other house
but you know he kicks me out of the bed
but get the heck out it's never happened
yeah but i do spend a lot of time out
there and uh
it's uh you know you gotta have a little
distance sometimes
you know you gotta know you're gonna
know your role and so all of a sudden
when you're a guy that's been gone your
whole life from
eight o'clock in the morning until close
to 7 30 or 8 o'clock at night so 11
12 hours a day then all of a sudden
you're not gone as much
even though you still work she's trying
to slow me down now i'm doing uh
not so much like here what we're doing
right now but when i get in the car and
drive somewhere
or fly somewhere you know like just last
night i just went to bed and i hadn't
told her that
this guy called me and he wants me to uh
speak for a
uh you want to build another wrestling
wants to
start another wrestlers in business
networking out in uh
delaware because we don't have any
colleges in wrestling in delaware
and so i said well you know you know
i'll gladly do that because that's my
life you know
so but then all of a sudden i i didn't
say anything to my wife until all of a
sudden
this morning and i told her that i might
go on the friday the 21st of december
i don't know well well i said that's not
christmas she goes we're celebrating
christmas that weekend
early because a lot of the family can't
be i'll be here except for that weekend
yeah and i said oh well that's not gonna
work
but i kind of didn't say anything to her
first and then
well i'll tell you she started getting a
little emotional and if i want to
stay married for another year 45 years
then i better tell those people that
i got family obligations because
uh that depends what's most important
yeah i love wrestling
i love wrestling and i want to start
another wes help
start another wrestlers and business
network but there's more than one dane
gable out there well maybe not but
but there's there's a lot of people that
are
um maybe even closer yeah
and they got big names i mean we're
we're doing pretty well right now i mean
we got first two years ago and we got
second this year uh and then we got the
women's freestyles doing good in
wrestling
we got to work a little bit on our greco
yet but
but they are working on it but our men's
freestyle team right now
are are excellent and
you know and uh the key for them
is to get them all on the same page
instead of just have new highlights
and by that i'm saying who look you look
and see who won this year well the three
guys that have never won before won this
year we had three world champions
our two past world champions
didn't win this year i mean they they
did okay you know they got medals
yeah did boros win no he did not he got
third
oh that's right he got bronze yeah
inside got i mean um
snyder got second so those two are our
main guys
you know so the three new guys that came
through
were guys that hadn't won world gold in
fact two of them have never made a world
team before
and so when we have three world
champions this year but we needed
all five of them to come through to win
the uh the championships
and so the key really is getting them
all
to do the same at the same time year in
and year out
and not just uh based on okay
uh beryl's got beat this year so he'll
win next year
it's got to be every year if you're
capable of doing that and that's what
the coaching staff has to do
it's kind of funny that i do have a lot
of influence actually on the coaching
staffs right now at the usa level
because the
the women's freestyle guy is uh is terry
steiner and he wrestled for me was a
national champion
he's got a twin brother that's at uh
fresno state
and then billy zaddick is the uh
freestyle coach
and he wrestled for the hawkeyes back in
uh uh the early days and uh he was the
national champion so
we got a lot of uh former gable
influence on there but
but he's got deep roots in there
you